the last time I was in the capital was
many years ago another wedding my sister
Elia and Rhaegar Targaryen the Last
Dragon my sister loved him she bore his
children swaddled them rocked them fed
them at her own breast
he wouldn't had the wagner's touched and
beautiful noble Rhaegar Targaryen left
her for another woman what's up ladies
and gentlemen welcome back to talking
thrones today I want to discuss one of
the biggest misconceptions in all of
Westeros and how this is going to affect
the upcoming season a Game of Thrones
which is the mysterious relationship
between Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
Stark Rhaegar Targaryen is the Mad King
son and Lyanna Stark is Ned Stark's
sister and I'm assuming that every
hardcore Game of Thrones fan is well
aware of these two characters by now but
there are still some fans out there that
aren't as familiar with everything that
is surrounding these two characters to
be honest with you there isn't much
information about this time period and
if you haven't read the books then you
know even less because the television
show has only mentioned Rhaegar and
Lyanna a few times and there are only a
few potential characters left in the
show who may know the truth about them
this is one of the best-kept secrets in
Westeros but before the game of Thrones
series ends the truth will come out and
it's going to send shockwaves across the
Seven Kingdoms from what we've seen in
the television show there is only one
side of this story known throughout
Westeros which is sometime around 280
1ac Lord Walter went held a tournament
at Harrenhal which was supposed to be
the Superbowl of all jousting
tournaments everyone who was anyone was
in attendance that day Arthur Dayne was
there Barristan Selmy Robert Baratheon
Palin read Benjen stark Ned Stark and
their sister Lyanna Stark Littlefinger
was even there the Mad King was there
and his son Rhaegar Targaryen who was
also participating in this tournament
but before any jousting even took place
there was a feast to celebrate the start
of the tournament basically a pregame
during this feast
targaryen started to sing a song that
was heard by many this song was said to
have sounded so beautiful that it
actually made Leon a start break down
into tears now this piece of information
sets the stage in tone for the
relationship between Rhaegar and Lyanna
this goes to show you that this man's
voice alone can have an emotional effect
only on a stark but this was just the
beginning over the course of several
days rhaegar targaryen starts to kick
ass at this tournament beating some of
the most legendary fighters in the world
but keep in mind this was just jousting
not sword fighting but it was still very
impressive nonetheless Rhaegar
eventually wins the tournament and he
takes the winner dros crown for the
queen of love and beauty and he walks
right past his wife and he gives it to
Lyanna stark instead this was a shocking
act by the prince that stunned the crowd
during season five Littlefinger tells
songs of that one Rhaegar one the crowd
erupted in tears for their prince but
when he rode past his wife to give the
crown to Liana all the smiles in
attendance died that day
when Rhaegar won everyone cheered for
their prince remember the girls laughing
when he took off his helmet and they saw
that silver hair how handsome he was
until he rode right past his wife and he
might tell and all the smiles died never
seen so many people so fired but Rhaegar
Targaryen gave zero [ __ ] his eyes
probably lit up like wildfire when he
got a scent of her wolves blood but the
tournay of Harrenhal ended and everyone
went back to their lives but the fire
inside Rhaegar Liana
didn't die and sometime after this
Rhaegar and Lyanna disappeared and this
is when the facts get fuzzy and people
of Westeros feared the worst
this is where the truth was hidden did
Rhaegar kidnap and rape Liana
or did she go willingly was Rhaegar
really in love with her or was this just
an evil act against the Starks
unfortunately for Prince Rhaegar
everyone thinks he kidnapped her and
repeatedly raped her Robert Baratheon
believes he raped her several times and
even songs of stark believes this lie
how many tens of thousands had to die
because Rhaegar chose your aunt yes he
chose her and then kidnapped and raped
in my opinion this is not what happened
my friends in season one we see Ned's
reaction to Roberts claim and it speaks
volumes in Aerys Targaryen has we'd some
Dothraki horselord what of it we send
her a wedding gift knife perhaps a good
sharp one and a bold man to wield it
she's little more than a child well soon
enough that child will spread her legs
and self breeding so men we're not
speaking of this I was unspeakable to
you what I fathered it's your family
that was unspeakable what Rhaegar
Targaryen did to your sister the woman I
loved
kill every Targaryen I get my hands on
you can't get your hands on this one
King Robert Baratheon was so angry and
he didn't understand why Ned wasn't
angry either even after he reminded me
that Rhaegar kidnapped and raped his
sister you know why Ned never got angry
that's because he knows the truth he is
one of the only people in the world who
actually know the truth about the loving
relationship between Rhaegar and his
sister Lyanna Ned didn't get angry
because he knows for a fact that Rhaegar
didn't kidnap and rape his sister Ned
spoke to Liana before she died he knew
she wasn't in any danger from Rhaegar in
fact Rhaegar had one of the best
swordsmen in history protecting Liana
and his son Jon Snow the prince that was
promised and based off the information
we know about Rhaegar Targaryen there is
no way someone should think that he is
the type of man to do something like
that even Barristan Selmy who was one of
the most noble men in history had
nothing but nice things to say about
Rhaegar I was thinking about all the
times your brother made me go with him
down from the red keep into the streets
of King's Landing why we like to walk
among the people they like to sing to
them he sang to him yes
Rhaegar would pick a spot on the hook or
the street of seeds anything just like
all the other minstrels and what did he
do I made sure no one killed him then I
collected the money
what like to see how much he could make
he was good he was very good deserves
never Zoli he told me a guy was good at
killing
like I never liked killing he loved
singing and what did you do with the
money well one time he gave it to the
next missile down the street one time he
gave it to an orphanage in flea bottom
rhaegar targaryen walked among the
people and sang and he gave money away
to the orphanage he was a man of the
people that doesn't sound like a man
that kidnapped and raped someone at
least not to me even in a dance with
dragons Barristan Selmy has appeal he
chapter and in that chapter he was
thinking to himself that Prince Rhaegar
loved his lady Liana and thousands died
for it
he would think about that because it was
the truth and Lyanna stark didn't want
to marry Robert Baratheon he already had
a reputation for being a [ __ ] and when
you want to knew that even marriage
wouldn't change that who would want to
marry someone that you couldn't trust
Daenerys Targaryen even had a vision at
the house of the undying enduring this
specific vision there is a dying prince
with rubies flying from his armor and he
is whispering the name of a woman with
his last breath she is seeing her
brother Rhaegar Targaryen at the Trident
and that was him whispering Leone his
name as Robert Baratheon smashes in his
chest with his Warhammer he is
whispering the name of the same woman
that ultimately caused Robert's
rebellion Rhaegar loved Liana and he was
willing to die for her and died he did
as of right now everyone in Westeros has
it wrong
Sansa is wrong for saying Rhaegar
kidnapped and raped Liana but the truth
is about to come out and Littlefinger
maybe one of them Lee a handful of
people that potentially know of this
information I know we all remember that
look Littlefinger gave songs of when she
said Liana was kidnapped and raped
Littlefinger seems to know everything
and he was even there at the tournament
when Rhaegar gave Liana the Roses
Littlefinger is a very observant man he
can read people and their intentions
pretty well he probably saw the way
Rhaegar and Lyanna was looking at each
other and knew there was more than meets
the eye even as a little kid I bet he
could tell it was one of those love at
first sight type of moments and this
information is going to play a big role
in season seven we've already seen
multiple promos from season seven and in
those promos we have seen the crypts of
Winterfell many times Littlefinger knows
the truth about Rhaegar and Lyanna and
he is on the verge of spilling the beans
we're about to learn so much
more about this time period george RR
martin even said on his blog that one
via Song of Ice and Fire series ends we
will know everything there is no about
Robert rebellion which is why we aren't
getting a Robert's rebellion prequel I
think there's a good chance we could get
a POV chapter of Liana or Rhaegar at the
tower of joy which will reveal all the
answers we've been waiting for about
their relationship but in the television
show we're going to find this out
through Littlefinger bran
Sam and possibly even Varys these are
the four men that can potentially hold
the truth in the most recent season 7
promo they show a brief scene of Sansa
standing in the crypts and they show
Littlefinger standing right at the
entrance of the crypts
I think Littlefinger and songs that may
share another scene down here again but
this time Littlefinger is probably going
to reveal the songs of the correct
version of the story purposely to put a
wedge between Songza and John I think
Littlefinger might tell songs oh you
know what remember when I tried to get a
reaction out of you by saying John was
your half-brother guess what he's not
your half-brother at all in fact he's a
Targaryen and he has no right to
Winterfell or the north
now that would definitely get a reaction
out of saunter and who knows what she
might think then also in the season 7
trailer there is a quick scene of John
and Littlefinger down in the crypts and
in that scene John grabs Littlefinger by
the throat and slams him up against the
wall now why do you think John would do
something like that when I made my
trailer breakdown video I had two
initial reactions to this scene John
grabbing Littlefinger by the throat must
be because of something about Shawn's o
or John's real parents they are standing
right next to lay on a statue and I
wouldn't be surprised that Littlefinger
made some smartass remark to John that
would make him question who his mother
or father is all of the season seven
prominence have been hinting at a major
scene revolving around John Shawn's ax
Littlefinger and the Crips
I think they keep showing us this for a
reason because Littlefinger is about the
start dropping bombshells in Winterfell
Littlefinger knows John has dragons
blood and Littlefinger is playing with
fire and his ass is about to get burned
Game of Thrones is about to reveal so
much more about Rhaegar and Lyanna and I
can't wait to find out the rest of the
truth
I think Littlefinger is going to start
dropping bombs brain is about to start
having visions at the tourney at
Harrenhal the battle at the Trident or
possibly even Rhaegar and Lyanna
arriving at the
of joy in the conversations they had
together whatever it is it's going to be
something big samwell tarly is also at
the citadel surrounded by the world's
history impossible secrets there's no
telling what all he might find out
george RR martin said we're going to
find out more about this time period and
i believe him so comment below and let
me know what you think what do you think
john and Littlefinger are talking about
down in the crypts that causes John to
grab him at the neck and slam him
against a wall
what flashbacks do you think bran will
get next I want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching this video I
really hope you enjoyed it and a big
thanks to my patreon supporters I love
all y'all and I'll see you down below
bye